من المتوقع أن يسلم الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
نفسه إلى
محكمة في مانهاتن، الثلاثاء، حيث
سيصبح أول رئيس سابق أو حالي يُتهم بارتكاب
جريمة.
ويواجه ترامب أكثر من 30 تهمة تتعلق
بالاحتيال التجاري بعد
تحقيق في دفع أموال سرية
لشخص بالغ.  النجمة السينمائية ستورمي دانيلز
قبل أيام من انتخابات عام 2016، كان هذا
إنفاقًا شخصيًا وليس إنفاقًا على الحملة الانتخابية،
في حين أن التهم الرسمية
لم تُعرف بعد، يقوم فريق ترامب القانوني
بالتحضير لمعركة، ينظر الفريق إلى
كل
قضية محتملة سنكون قادرين عليها.
للطعن وسنطعن فيه،
كان ترامب نشطًا على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الخاصة به
حيث وصف المدعي العام لمنطقة مانهاتن
ألفين براج بأنه ذو
دوافع سياسية وادعى أن القاضي الذي
يشرف على قضيته يقتبس عنه أنه يكرهه، ويقول سلف
براد إن هذه التصريحات
يمكن أن تعزز القضية المرفوعة ضده،
وسأكون على دراية بذلك  عدم ارتكاب بعض
الجرائم الجنائية الأخرى مثل عرقلة
الحكومة والإدارة التي
تتدخل في أو أه عن طريق التهديد
أو غير ذلك من عمل الحكومة.
ترامب في منتصف محاولته الأخيرة
للرئاسة وأحدث
منافسيه يقول حاكم أركنساس السابق
آسا هاتشينسون  إن
التحقيقات المتعددة بشأن ترامب تخبر
الناخبين بأنها يجب أن تمنح الأمريكيين وقفة